hey ice cream today we are in little
damage in downtown Los Angeles and I
thought an ice cream that reminds me a
little bit of you really what is it it's
monochromatic it's all black and called
the goth ice cream I'm ready for them
what is your most popular Instagram
famous thing here our most popular is by
far the black roses so that's like the
black soft-serve ice cream and actually
what we use to color is activated
charcoal it is safe to eat it's charcoal
yeah it is six eat actually charcoal
looks like to talk to pine and the
flavor is just like a vanilla rose
flavors really I'm being healthy by
eating black rice treat it yeah yeah
let's do it
does this so me look at this it
literally looks like you're cooler than
me
she's right yeah
it's like really soft and melty and not
too cold that's quality it does it
tastes slightly floral
I don't usually Instagram food well I
will integrate this they're the only
instagrams check it out on the Instagram
chicken it's like you're an evil villain
with a heart of gold and that's what you
have I don't want to tweak this I like
it as it is
wait Evan I think they have a unicorn
why should we try the unicorn one okay
cheers Cheers hey Thank You kids pretty
sure this is Kate banner I like what
it's melting and it looks like it's
crying onto the black it's living out
your name unicorn - this is me that is
decision actually imagine me it does
Metra sweaters how did we accidentally
match our food today will damage I feel
like I'm at the damage in every way and
you can tell this whole place is for
Instagram I was also I was really
surprised I had rows and like black who
would've thought right wait until it
wasn't delivered I really liked it
I totally understand why this is blowing
up on Instagram really cool to look at
super new and interesting and fresh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]